I don't think Olaf should get to
rearrange um I don't think Olaf should
get to rearrange this is gonna be a
cinch two sisters one mind okay here we
go
you got this Elsa anytime just do
something with your body um nothing
err tree people Trippel is that a word
that's not a word Oh
shovel boy teeth Oh pillow forts so in
the library playing charades
yeah and this you Olaf has just won
because he can rearrange right and so
Christophe got him bang bang bang it's
boys against girls you're not a huge fan
of that but you have complete faith in
you guys and you and Elsa okay the key
to this and I say have fun play with
whatever you come up with is Elsa is so
bad at charades it's almost impossible
to come up with writing so I said just
just play okay I see what you've got
okay lion briefly bear monster I'm very
angry bear I'm a demon on slightest
mistake of your life we didn't even kiss
you we all kind of got it
did we hurt your feelings I'm so sorry
if we did you know very few people are
actually good at family games that's
just a fact we made a promise not to
shut each other out just tell me what's
going on you're not going alone
well you're not going alone excuse me I
climbed the North Mountain survived a
frozen heart and saved you from my
ex-boyfriend and I did it all without
powers so you know I'm coming okay so
it's just you confronting her a little
bit and also it's just trying to hang on
to her - no I think you're starting to
sense if she's pulling away a little bit
so it's like come back
to me also come back okay Christophe can
I borrow your wagon and Sven mm-hmm I'm
not very comfortable with the idea of
that you are not going alone oh no no I
have my powers to protect me
you don't excuse me I climbed to the
North Mountain survived a frozen heart
and saved you from my ex-boyfriend and I
did it all without powers so you know
I'm coming me too I'll Drive oh I will
look after your people please make sure
they stay out of the kingdom until we
return of course let's let them know
honour I'm worried for her we have
always feared Elsa's powers were too
much for this world
now we must pray they are enough I won't
let anything happen to her the next
right thing is for me to go to the
enchanted forest and find that voice
Kristoff can I borrow your wagon and
Sven I woke the magical spirits of the
enchanted forest because of the voice
because of the voice I know it sounds
crazy but I believe whoever is calling
me is good I know we did this together
and we'll continue to do this together
Anna I need to ask you a question Anna I
need to ask you a question Anna I need
to ask you a question do you want to
build a snowman so that's what this is
really about you're finally confessing
it although not an ominous voice it
feels something about it feels right
yeah it feel it's speaking to your magic
in this way that says it's good and it's
not something anyone else can understand
but you appeal to Anna and she will she
will understand she's your sister so
that's all these aren't okay cool
okay Olaf you're up okay I'm ready I'm
ready
go unicorn ice cream castle oaken teapot
Mouse Oh Elsa okay Olaf you're up okay
so much easier now that I can read mmm
lightning round boys against girls I'm
ready I'm ready go
unicorn ice-cream castle oaken teapot
Mouse Oh Elsa I don't think Olaf should
get to rearrange did you know sleeping
quietly on long journeys prevents
insanity did you know sleeping quietly
on long journeys prevents insanity Olaf
did you know sleeping quietly on long
journeys prevents insanity
Sven keep us steady will you honor
mhmmm honor remember our first trip like
this when I said you'd have to be crazy
to want to marry a man you just met no I
did but you were not crazy
clearly huh just naive not naive just
new to love like I was and when you're
new you're bound to get it wrong what no
no no no I'm not saying you're wrong or
crazy I'm saying that it's nothing's
gonna happen to arond Oh Anna it's gonna
be fine
come here you know under different
circumstances this would be a pretty
romantic place don't you think just in
case we don't make it out of here no no
no I mean we will make it out of here
well technically the odds are kind of
complicated but my point is in case we
die no no no no we will die at some
point but not at any recent time will we
die no but wait in the future we will
don't patronize me
reindeers are better than people Sven
why is love so hard you feel what you
feel and those feelings are real come on
Kristoff let down your guard
bird the gang's doing charades okay
Jonathan so you are on a team with Olaf
okay and boys against girls and Olaf can
rearrange very easily and do these
shapes that hardly anyone else can do
you get the stuff right away instantly
he does it so you're you're right on it
with all of these these lines hairs so
yeah and this one here it's because Olaf
as almost acting out and slicing the air
like she's got a sword guesses Hans
which she's like it's close right and
you of course
loving this yes this is the greatest
greatest mistake of your life yeah you
got it
Oh I'm just living the dream honor oh
I'm just living the dream honor oh how I
wish this could last forever and yet
change mocks us with her beauty and yet
change mocks us with her beauty forgive
me maturity is making me poetic tell me
you're older in the song knowing do you
ever worry about the notion that nothing
is permanent you're living the dream
you're lying in the Sun and just as
you're doing that it's starting to cool
down and then a leaf of fall falls and
symbolizing change and this is also
symbolizing your maturity which is going
to okay be a big part of this film it's
all on you so this is this is me setting
up the themes of our movie so I'm one I
want to nail this I don't want to throw
this away no okay in a way that's funny
think got it okay enjoying your new
permafrost Oh God I'm just living the
dream honor oh how I wish this could
last forever and yet change mocks us
with her beauty what's that
forgive me maturity is making me poetic
tell me you're older and thus
all-knowing do you ever worry about the
notion then nothing is permanent
no you I can't wait until I'm aged like
you so I don't have to worry about
important things yeah I'm tired too and
spend promised to read me a bedtime
story do you
son it's fan promise to read me a
bedtime story you know you should come
here I come here do the best voices like
when you pretend to be cry stuff and
you're like hey I just need to go talk
to some rocks about my childhood and
stuff oh yeah
we're calling this controlling what you
can when things feel out of control oh
yeah
we're calling this controlling what you
can when things feel out of control what
he's sitting with a group of kids who
they're you know they're all those
crystals that fall yes they are
decorating him with the crystals and so
he looks ridiculous oh yeah she's got
it's all those crystals so he's talking
as they're yet creative so Christophe
said you know how you doing there Olaf
and he's very he's it's just showing the
generosity of Olaf and he's looking
after the kids and he's giving some
really good advice on how you help kids
get through difficult to talk okay
first we do that and then and then so
this is more like it's it's he's kind of
being like pensive and then this is a
separate this is separate after that and
that's later when everyone's like we're
going I'm going I'm coming I'm coming
I'll bring the snack so that makes just
fun to get I'm coming me too
I'll Drive I'll bring hey did you know
did you know
men are six times more likely to be
struck by lightning
does that include snowmen only time will
tell only time and weather conditions
will doubt
did you know gorillas burp when they're
happy go to zoo test it out
well well you're the grown ups you know
can I try something a little different
better no not better just different well
well that was unanimous then I'm still
gonna look it up when I get home
okay so now it also stands on the
shoreline of the dark sea and we see we
start with crash this lightning and we
go back and we see this figure who's all
set I'm looking out over the sea maybe's
roaring turbulent waves she gives a
little look just gonna do a little like
hmm I got this sort of Nod
[Music]
aren't cut they all essentially stand
here there no she's drenched she's right
back where she started and she takes off
again she's running running ready and we
see the waves she was past camera and
leaps over the first set of waves as
they crash down as she forms this little
ice ramp that she slides down and she
runs again on the waves this time she's
getting close to making it but a huge
wave is forming and she shoots with her
ice forming this giant like iceberg type
thing that she was going to run up but
it doesn't work and it comes crashing
down onto her and she plunges down into
the into the ocean and the camera goes
now underwater as we see the roller goes
by and in between here she'll start
swimming and it's really really dark and
the lightning will flash and that'll
light up Elsa and then at the very end
because she's swimming we see a
lightning flash which reveals but not
course for them
[Music]
this is gonna be a cinch two sisters one
mind okay here we go
you got this Elsa anytime just do
something with your body I know we did
this together and we'll continue to do
this together Anna and you to ask you a
question do you want to build a snowman